♪ ♪
>> Tucker: JEFFREY EPSTEIN’S
CONSIGLIO AREA REPEATEDLY HIS
HAS BEEN ARRESTED AND CHARGED
WITH A NUMBER OF TIMES INCLUDING
SEX TRAFFICKING, HER NAME
APPARENTLY IS PRONOUNCED "GALEN"
MAXWELL, SPELLED GHISLAINE.
MAXWELL IS JUST AS BAD AS THE
BILLIONAIRE.
>> SHE IS A RAPIST.
SHE DESTROYED WHAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE THE BEST YEARS OF MY LIFE.
SHE IS JUST AS EVIL AS
JEFFREY EPSTEIN AS EVERYBODY HAS
PAINTED HIM TO BE.
MS. MAXWELL WAS HIS BUSINESS
PARTNER IN THIS.
SHE DID THIS TO MANY GIRLS.
IT WAS A HATEFUL AND DEGRADING
RAPE AND I WAS DUMPED OFF IN MY
GRANDPARENTS YARD NAKED AND WAS
TOLD THAT I WOULDN’T COME
BACK ALIVE THE NEXT TIME.
>> Tucker: ANOTHER ALLEGED
VICTIM TOLD "60 MINUTES"
AUSTRALIA ABOUT HOW MAXWELL
ENSNARED YOUNG GIRLS.
>> HIS PRIVATE SANCTUARY, AN
ISOLATED PRISON KNOWN AS THE
ISLAND WHERE HE WOULD SHARE THE
GIRLS LIKE PRAY WITH HIS
RICH AND POWERFUL FRIENDS.
>> WE WEREN’T ANYTHING IMPORTANT
TO THEM AT ALL.
WE WEREN’T EVEN A HUMAN BEING TO
THEM.
WE WERE JUST ANOTHER TOY TO BE
PASSED AROUND.
AND THAT’S WHAT THEY DID.
PRINCE ANDREW SHOULD BE
PANICKING AT THE MOMENT.
BECAUSE GHISLAINE DOESN’T REALLY
CARE ABOUT ANYONE ELSE BUT
GHISLAINE.
I WAS IN THE CAR WITH HER AND
SHE WOULD ASK THE DRIVER TO STOP
THE CAR, AND SHE WOULD -- ACROSS
TO THE SCHOOL OR THE PARK OR
WHEREVER SHE WAS GOING AND SHE W
NUMBER FOR A CHILD, A YOUNG
GIRL, AND THEN I WOULD SEE THAT
CHILD AT THE HOUSE.
SHE WOULD SAY THEY ARE ADDITION.
I FOUND A MODEL IN THE PARK AND
I THOUGHT IT WAS REALLY STRANGE
BECAUSE I DID SEE A COUPLE GIRLS
AND BRACES AND I’VE NEVER SEEN A
MODEL WITH BRACES.
>> Tucker: THAT’S DISGUSTING.
MAXWELL HAS NOW BEEN ARRESTED
BUT THEN OF COURSE
JEFFREY EPSTEIN WAS ARRESTED
TOO.
HOW CONFIDENT CAN THE REST MUST
BE THAT MAXWELL WILL REVEAL WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED ON THE
ISLAND AND OTHER PLACES?
WHO WAS INVOLVED, WHO PAID FOR
IT WITH THEIR FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS?
HOW CONFIDENT CAN WE BE SHE WILL
MAKE IT TO A COURTROOM.
GAVIN IS A RETIRED DEPUTY WARDEN
FOR THE NEW YORK CITY DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS, THE MAN TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT MAXWELL
WON’T MAKE IT TO COURT?
>> I THINK THERE ARE SOME ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE TO CONTEND WITH.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO JEFFREY EPSTEIN, HE
SUPPOSEDLY COMMITTED SUICIDE IN
PRISON?
I DON’T THINK SO.
DR. MICHAEL BADEN, RENOWNED
PATHOLOGIST, EXAMINE
JEFFREY EPSTEIN AND HE
DETERMINED THAT THE HYOID BONE
WAS FRACTURED AND THAT’S MORE
CONSISTENT WITH HOMICIDE BY
STRANGULATION INSTEAD OF SUICIDE
BY HANGING.
OF COURSE THE CAMERAS
CONVENIENTLY WEREN’T WORKING.
I DON’T THINK THE FEDS CAN
HANDLE THESE PRISONERS.
SUCH HIGH-PROFILE PRISONERS LIKE
MAXWELL OR EPSTEIN.
IF I WERE WILLIAM BARR, WHAT I
WOULD DO IS I WOULD SEEK TO
OBTAIN A SUBSTITUTE JAIL ORDER
THAT I WOULD TRY TO HAVE
MS. MAXWELL PLACE ON RIKERS
ISLAND WITH THE NEW YORK CITY
APARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
THE JAILS ARE EMPTY BECAUSE
DE BLASIO HAS POLICE REFORM"
WILL HAS BAIL REFORMS EVERYBODY
EVERYBODY’S ON THE STREET SO
THERE’S PLENTY OF ROOM AT THE
END ON RIKERS AND THEN WE HAVE
AN EMERGENCY SERVICES UNIT
THAT COULD HANDLE HER AND I
THINK THAT’S THE BEST THING THAT
COULD HAPPEN AND THE REASON I
SAY THAT IS BECAUSE THE JAIL SHE
IS CURRENTLY IN, METROPOLITAN
DETENTION CENTER IN BROOKLYN, IT
THE SEXUAL ABUSE OF FEMALE
INMATES.
LET ME GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES.
IN 2011 THERE WAS A FEMALE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER THERE.
SHE HAD SEX ON DUTY WITH EIGHT
EMPLOYEES, TWO WERE SUPERIOR
OFFICERS.
SHE ALSO HAD SEX WITH TWO
INMATES.
ONE WAS A GANG BANGER AND A
DRUG DEALER AND THE OTHER KILLED
NEW YORK CITY POLICE DETECTIVES
AND FINALLY WE HAVE A LIEUTENANT
AND TWO CORRECTION OFFICERS
RECENTLY WERE CONVICTED OF
SEXUALLY ABUSING OVER TEN WOMEN.
THE LIEUTENANT WAS IN CHARGE OF
THE UNIT.
ONE OF HIS FUNCTIONS WAS TO
TEACH THE OFFICERS ABOUT THE
PRESENT RAPE ELIMINATION ACT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE, THE GUY WHO WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE TRAINING OFFICERS
HOW TO PREVENT RAPE IN PRISON IS
ACTUALLY RAPING THE INMATES.
I DO THINK THE FACILITIES
CAPABLE OF HANDLING IT.
THERE’S TOO MUCH THAT’S GOING ON
THERE RECENTLY AND I DON’T THINK
ANY FEMALE INNOVATE SHOULD BE
HOUSED THERE AND ANOTHER THING I
FIRMLY BELIEVE, I DON’T BELIEVE
FEMALE INMATES SHOULD BE HOUSE
IN THE SAME FACILITY WITH MALE
INMATES.
DOESN’T MAKE ANY SENSE AND WE
NEED TO CHANGE THAT.
>> Tucker: UNLESS YOU BELIEVE
THERE IS NO DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE SEXES IN WHICH CASE YOU ARE
A MORON.
I’LL LINK ANYBODY MOURNS THE
DEATH OF JEFFREY EPSTEIN IS A
MAN BUT WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT
THE COUNTRY WHEN A GUY CAN BE
POSSIBLY MURDERED IN A JAIL
CELL.
IT SUGGESTS THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
PLAYED ALONG WITH THAT, PEOPLE
WHO WERE SUPPOSED TO BE WATCHING
HIM, PERHAPS OFFICIAL OF THE
FACILITY.
WHY ARE NOT OF THEM IN DEEP
TROUBLE RIGHT NOW.
WHY DON’T WE KNOW THE TRUTH?
I DON’T UNDERSTAND.
>> I’LL TELL YOU WHY.
WE HAVE CORRUPT POLICE
OFFICIALS.
WE HAVE CORRUPT OFFICIALS AT THE
FBI AND WE HAVE CORRUPT
OFFICIALS IN THE U.S. ATTORNEY’S
OFFICE.
LOOK AT WHAT JEFFREY EPSTEIN DID
DID.
GOING BACK TEN OR 15 YEARS AGO.
HE PAID MONEY TO THE PALM BEACH
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
POLICE DEPARTMENT SHOULDN’T BE
ACCEPTING MONEY FROM PRIVATE
CITIZENS.
WHAT SEX OFFENDER, WHAT
SEX OFFENDER GETS WORK RELEASED
FROM JAIL?
THE PALM BEACH COUNTY SHERIFF’S
OFFICE IS FACILITATING THAT.
EPSTEIN FORMED A COMPANY SO THAT
HE COULD PAY DEPUTY SHERIFFS TO
BABYSIT HIM WHILE HE WAS ON WORK
RELEASE.
I WAS A DEPUTY WARDEN AT A
NEW YORK CITY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY IN 2000 AND WE HOUSE
ABOUT 400 SEX OFFENDERS.
I NEVER HAD ONE SEX OFFENDER
THAT WAS RELEASED ON WORK
RELEASE.
IT’S UNHEARD OF.
SO THEN YOU HAVE THE STATES
ATTORNEY WAY BACK WHEN WHO
DIDN’T EVEN BOTHER TO INTERVIEW
THE CHILDREN OR THEIR PARENTS.
AS YOU KNOW, TUCKER, I’VE BEEN
DOING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INVESTIGATIONS FOR THE LAST 14
YEARS ON THE STREETS OF NEW YORK
SO I KNOW A LOT ABOUT THAT AND
CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES WAS
NEVER NOTIFIED.
FAMILY COURT WAS NEVER NOTIFIED
AND SOCIAL SERVICES NEVER HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT THOSE
CHILDREN SO LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
BLOWN THIS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, TEN
YEARS LATER THEY ARREST
JEFFREY EPSTEIN AT AN AIRPORT?
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, THEY FIND
THIS CLOWN UP IN NEW HAMPSHIRE?
GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> Tucker: I TOTALLY AGREE.
>> THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES THAT HAVE HANDLE
THIS, IT’S BIZARRE.
I’VE NEVER HEARD OF ANYTHING
LIKE IT.
I DO NOT TRUST THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE INVOLVED IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: RIGHT, SO INSTEAD
THEY ARE CRUSHING LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS.
I AGREE.
GIVE ME YOUR TEN SECONDS.
ED, THANK YOU FOR THAT,